-on j'ai pas mes petits la connaît oui
ça chauffe ça devrait bien aller
voilà si tu la connais tu qui très fort
ok je crois oui je crois
nous croyons vous voyez il ou elle le
droit aux jours meilleurs
rien au genre meilleur meilleur
tiens mon grand père tout cas une jambe
de bois
est ce que tu crois qu'ils désespèrent
dont il boit et puis il boit plus il y
croit tout son coeur aux beaux jours
meilleurs
je dois d où jonathan et que la dent
dans mes sous wadja l'attendent
il a bon coeur il les attend de tout son
coeur des jours meilleurs objets rémy
n'a plus de dents à la plus qu'une aile
l'accident il cause comme d'un groupe du
ve mais s'ils y croient au jour mais je
prends tu crois
dilou est le roi nous prions nous
voyaient ils ou elles croient aux jours
meilleurs
mais un beau jour meilleur meilleur tu
as ton fusil et tout rouillé et toi
aussi tu es vous mouiller du shass quand
même et c'est pour ça qu'on t'aime
quel de chasseurs des jours meilleurs
monsieur isaac qui étaient partis posé
son sac web par ali il a fallu il a
compris qu'ils sont ici va d'ailleurs
les jours meilleurs tiens tiens prends
ma soeur qui se permettait quelques
erreurs en société en privé qu'elle va
se marier au vieux pasteur faut les
gagner ces jours meilleurs
je crois tu crois y louait le croire
nous croyons neuf foyers où le croit aux
jours meilleurs